[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien in allen einen schönen
guten Abend Norbert König hat heute den
Sport zum Sonntag ja den haben wir guten
Abend dann schauen wir jetzt gemeinsam
auf die Themen unserer heutigen Sendung
Koalition streitet über
Kindergrundsicherung Finanzminister
Lindner findet die Pläne der Grünen zu
teuer
Tod auf der Landstraße in Thüringen
Gerät ein Mann ohne Führerschein in den
Gegenverkehr er überlebt sieben Menschen
sterben
und Erfolg auf hoher See der Segler
Boris Hermann gewinnt die Königsetappe
des Ocean Race
[Musik]
kaum verständigte sich die Ampel mühsam
auf einen klimakompromiss liegt schon
der nächste Streit in der Luft es geht
um die im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbarte
Kindergrundsicherung da bestehen die
Grünen auf zusätzliche Milliarden der
FDP Finanzminister sieht dafür aber
keinen Spielraum für die grüne
Familienministerin ist die
Kindergrundsicherung ein zentrales Thema
denn in Deutschland ist jedes fünfte
Kind von Armut bedroht ab 2025 soll die
Kinder Grundsicherung die bisherigen
staatlichen Leistungen bündeln wie
Kindergeld Bürgergeld und den
Kinderzuschlag für Eltern mit geringem
Einkommen die Gold Dieckmann berichtet
ein warmes Essen am Tag für viele Kinder
gibt es das nur dank Hilfsprojekten ein
Instrument im Kampf gegen Kinderarmut
die Kinder Grundsicherung ihre Reform
hat sich die Ampel in den
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben die
Kindergrundsicherung ist das
sozialpolitische Projekt dieser
Koalition und deswegen muss sie auch ein
klares Signal senden an die Ärmsten
unserer Gesellschaft dass sie
unterstützt werden und deswegen müssen
wir da auch über relevantes Geld reden
aber die Ampel redet nicht sondern sie
streitet die Ministerin will die
Leistungen ausweiten und fordert 12
Milliarden heute erneut klare Absage vom
Bundesfinanzminister der unter anderem
auf das bereits erhöhte Kindergeld
verweist
insgesamt stellen wir Familien und
Kindern 7 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr mehr
zur Verfügung das Wesentliche für die
Kindergrundsicherung ist damit
finanziell getan mehr ist immer
wünschenswert aber nicht immer möglich
die SPD springt Lindner zur Seite es
gehe nicht darum die Zahl der
Anspruchsberechtigten zu steigern
sondern die Zahl derer die die Kinder
Grundsicherung auch wirklich beantragen
derzeit ist es so dass nur etwa ein
Drittel der Eltern und Kinder die den
Kinderzuschlag bekommen könnten ihn
tatsächlich auch beantragen weil es
einfach zu kompliziert ist und weil die
Leute auch was anderes zu tun haben
Sozialverbände üben massive Kritik
die Familienministerin hat ca 12
Milliarden Euro angemeldet für die
Kinder Grundsicherung und ich finde
darüber sollte jetzt nicht gehandelt und
gefälscht werden sondern hier geht es
tatsächlich um ein Projektes extrem
wichtig ist für Menschen wie weit will
die Ampel sich strecken die Kinder
Grundsicherung eine weitere grundlegende
Frage in der die Koalition über Kreuz
liegt
wir gehen nach Berlin zu Theo call Theo
wieder unterschiedliche Ansichten bei
einem gemeinsamen koalitionsvorhaben
droht hier schon der nächste große
regierungszopf
also dafür spricht jedenfalls einiges
wichtige spitzenvertreterinnen der
Grünen haben sehr deutlich gemacht wie
wichtig Ihnen dieses Thema ist und die
Grünen sind gerade wahrlich nicht so
gestimmt dass sie der FDP bzw dem
Finanzminister noch weit Entgegenkommen
wollen das Ergebnis des
Koalitionsausschusses wird ja von einem
nicht unwesentlichen Teil der Grünen als
überwiegende Niederlage angesehen die
Zugeständnisse unter anderem bei der
Autobahn Erweiterung und bei den
zwingenden co2-zielen im Verkehr die
werden als nicht gleichwertig empfunden
zu den erreichten Klimaschutzmaßnahmen
das hat die Fronten bei den Grünen
spürbar verhärtet auch wenn das nach
außen keiner so deutlich sagt und rein
politisch strategisch können Sie sich
jetzt mittels Kindergrundsicherung beim
Finanzminister reagieren vielen Dank für
die Hintergründe nach Berlin Teo
in Bulgarien haben die Menschen heute
ein neues Parlament gewählt und zwar
schon zum fünften Mal innerhalb von zwei
Jahren in dem ärmsten Land der EU
scheiterten zuletzt alle Versuche eine
stabile Regierung zu bilden die
stärksten Lager im Parlament sind pro
westlich und stehen an der Seite der
Ukraine wirtschaftliche und kulturell
ist Bulgarien aber auch Russisch geprägt
Wolf Christian Ulrich
deutsch-bulgarisches Teamwork mit
Rekordtempo in nur fünf Monaten bauen
sie die größte Solarfarm Bulgariens
Innovation die 150 Leuten Arbeit bringt
doch eher trotz und nicht wegen der
Politik denn in Bulgarien herrscht seit
mehr als einem Jahr politischer
Ausnahmezustand
für unsere Industrie und für die Bürger
ist es wirklich ärgerlich dass sich alle
sechs Monate politisch die Richtung
ändert ohne klare Linie
grüne Energie könnte Bulgarien
unabhängig machen von russlandsöl
Russlands Einfluss ist doch sonst
präsent nicht nur durch intensive online
Propaganda selbst der sozialistische
Präsident des nato-mitgliedsstaats
fordert
wir halten uns bei Waffenlieferungen an
die Ukraine raus und unterstützen das
auch nicht
die meisten Bulgaren sind pro westlich
eingestellt auch die Favoriten heute die
durch Korruptionsfälle belastete
konservative geldpartei unter dem
langjährigen Ministerpräsidenten
Borissow und das Reform Bündnis für
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und Kiril Petkov
doch wegen des streithema ist Korruption
kommen sie nicht zusammen
es muss eine Regierung geben nach dieser
Wahl denn die Leute haben inzwischen die
Nase voll
für Bulgarien geht es jetzt um EU
Milliarden Schengen Beitritt und
Euroeinführung noch eine Hängepartie
kann sich das Land nicht leisten
Bulgarien braucht Entscheidungen aber
die politische Szene ist so polarisiert
schwer vorstellbar wie da eine Koalition
oder eine Minderheitsregierung
funktionieren kann Ergebnisse am Abend
doch bulgarien hat wenig Hoffnung auf
eine stabile Regierung
im russischen St Petersburg ist bei
einem Bombenanschlag auf einen Kaffee
ein Mensch getötet 16 weitere sind
verletzt worden bei dem Opfer handelt es
sich um einen bekannten russischen
militärbericht der Starter und Blogger
das bestätigte das Innenministerium in
Moskau Hintergründe sind noch nicht
bekannt
ein verheerender Verkehrsunfall in
Thüringen macht fassungslos sieben
Menschen starben auf einer Landstraße
bei Bad Langensalza darunter 5
19-Jährige Ministerpräsident ramelo
reagierte bestürzt der Unfall
Verursacher war möglicherweise
alkoholisiert und hatte nach Angaben der
Polizei keine Fahrerlaubnis Daniela
Sonntag
ausgebrannte Autowracks die Trümmer
zeigen wie heftig die Kollision auf der
B247 bei Bad Langensalza gewesen ist es
war dieser BMW der nach ersten
Erkenntnissen in den Gegenverkehr
krachte der Fahrer laut Polizei ohne
Führerschein außerdem unter
alkoholverdacht er überlebt die anderen
Fahrzeuge aber gehen in Flammen auf in
dem einen Fahrzeug verbrannten fünf
Jugendliche im Alter von 19 Jahren in
dem zweiten Fahrzeug verbrannte der
60-jährige Fahrer auch ein Insasse des
BMW stark giftige rauchbehinderte die
Retter die Opfer konnten erst nach den
Löscharbeiten geborgen werden die
Einsatzkräfte an ihrer Grenze ja
versuchen jetzt hier gemeinsam im Team
im Gemeinschaft das Gesehene
aufzuarbeiten und zu verarbeiten wie es
zu dem Unfall kam sollen jetzt Gutachten
klären
die Musik und Filmwelt trauert um den
japanischen Komponisten Rio
[Musik]
weltberühmt wurde er mit seiner Musik zu
Mary Christmas Mister Lorenz dort auch
als Schauspieler neben David Bowie der
Soundtrack für den Film der letzte
Kaiser bescherte ihm 1988 einen Oscar
[Musik]
Elektropop Techno und Avon Guard all das
prägte er maßgeblich mit Sakamoto wurde
71 Jahre alt
wir machen sportlich weiter mit Norbert
und der Formel 1 genau und mit dem
gewohnten Sieger aber einem durchaus
ungewöhnlichen Rennen der zweimalige
Weltmeister Max Verstappen ist schon
wieder auf Titel Kurs er gewinnt in
Melbourne ein Rennen das jede Menge
Spektakel zu bieten hatte
drei Rennen Unterbrechungen nach roter
Flagge immer wieder musste der Enge Kurs
in Melbourne nach Unfällen aufwendig
gereinigt werden
ganz schön viel schief gegangen in 58
Rennrunden letztlich hat dieses
Überholmanöver von Verstappen gegen
Hamilton in der 12 Runde die
Vorentscheidung über den Sieg gebracht
Nico Hülkenberg im Harz 7
ganz vorne aber Weltmeister Max
Verstappen vor Lewis Hamilton und
Fernando Alonso
beim ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga Köln und
Mönchengladbach trennen sich im
rheinischen Derby vor 50.000 Fans torlos
Platz 1 nach 36 und 23.600 Kilometer in
das Team malizia um Skipper Boris
Hermann gewinnt die dritte Etappe des
Ocean Race von Südafrika nach Brasilien
und liegt damit in der Gesamtwertung auf
Platz 2
Champagner knapp 35 Tage nach Start in
Kapstadt seliges Grinsen bei Boris
Herrmann Sieg auf der Königsetappe des
Ocean Race wir waren bis zuletzt
unheimlich fokussiert und konzentriert
vor allem wollte ich nicht wieder gegen
den Fischerboot fahren ist er nicht
schon ein Kap Horn das Hermann Boot von
dann nach knapp 15.000 Seemeilen am Ende
der Etappe einen Kopf an Kopf Rennen mit
den Gesamtführenden Schweizern die
malizia besteht den Härtetest inklusive
Rückstand Mastbruch und segelverlust die
Belohnung Sieger der härtesten Etappe
Hermann und Cru erste in brasilianischen
interie weiter geht's für die malizia in
der April Boris Hermann gönnt sich
möglicherweise dann mal eine Auszeit
und ein Ziel in Genua kommen sie in
einem Vierteljahr ziemlich genau außen
Langzeitprojekt tolle Bilder waren sie
jeweils Dankeschön Norbert wir schauen
jetzt noch gemeinsam aus Wetter morgen
scheint oft die Sonne im Nordosten und
an den Alpen ist es stärker bewölkt aber
nur selten schneit es dann leicht bei
mäßigem Nordostwind werden drei bis elf
Grad erreicht die kommende Tage werden
dann meist freundlich im Nordosten kann
es vereinzelt etwas regnen wir empfehlen
noch das heute journal um 21 Uhr mit
eine gerinnek bedanken uns fürs zusch